hi everyone i'm naomi osaka i'm cordee
and this is the gq couple's quiz
what's my favorite meal
sushi cordee what specifically does she
like when you guys get sushi
i have no idea i'm not even like you get
sushi
i know the base of it is sushi i don't
eat sushi at all
which of your shows was the first that i
went to it was
the um oh so this is mad early actually
i want to say it was the one at the roxy
this is like before the album came out
so it was at the roxy
well i thought the show was really cool
i haven't really been to a lot of
concerts before so i thought it was
really cool plus i kind of knew him
personally so
that made it kind of more fun how old
was i
when i first won the us open
now we just talked about this a couple
days ago he was 21.
oh he was 20. he was 20. he wasn't 21.
he was 20.
where did we first meet and what did i
think of you
what did you think of me yes we first
met at the clippers game
and uh what did you first think of me
i'm like man this is
handsome what excuse me
i don't know you probably like damn you
gonna go to the lakers
well do you remember what you did
what i thought you were clumsy remember
yeah yeah because you knocked over the
class yeah i was i was
clumsy at that moment in time i'm not
anymore though
what is my biggest fear
i want to talk about your fears on
camera okay
you know what i'm saying that's that's
top secret information okay
i want to skip it though yeah what was
our most
memorable date that time i took you
we drove to rhode island from new york
to go like visit my grandmother
that was super tight it was it was cool
what city was i
born in osaka japan oh wow
that was that was a nerve-wracking bonus
how old was i when i moved to the us
i don't know i think he was like you
told me he was like four
two five three he was three
i was right there i was right there in
the ballpark area you gotta give me that
one
okay i'm technically crushing it
what are we being technical what's my
favorite thing to do
at home chill watch tv
read paint okay
you are a great cook though thanks
what is my biggest pet peeve
you just like everything to be clean and
in order
everybody clean up behind themselves
it's amazing because you don't do that
wow so you know who is my biggest
influence there's more than one
right or could should i just go to the
single another number one well
let me just hear your answers i would
say
um because you're so multifaceted serena
you know for obvious reasons
and then like beyonce and rihanna
because of
their fashion and business acumen and
nicki minaj too and thank you
you know it was all right all right
whatever
saves my parents all right so i got that
all
my bad mom where and when was our first
kiss
what yeah i remember i remember i'm
being funny
what you call it it's the spot in the
desert
you know what i'm talking about a spot
in the desert you know
indian wells right yeah he says wearing
men
indian wells okay
i'm not even asking this i have
questions in my head
what is my favorite thing that you do
for me
please excuse me
what is it what do you mean you're
supposed to answer the question i'm not
supposed to answer the question
for you can we skip this one
it has to do with i'm trying to think
okay we're gonna do something easy
okay what is my favorite color
black okay
when did i first start tennis he was
like five
did i get down right wrong how old was
you
three oh you need to be more
enthusiastic about answering these
questions sir
mother you get too chillaxed what would
i be if i wasn't a tennis player
fashion designer dash model
what is my hidden talent
you can paint and draw pretty well
i have the point where is the place that
i haven't traveled to that i really want
to go
oh hint you have also haven't been there
africa i want to go to south africa
it doesn't matter to me i just need to
be in the motherland so
i'm assuming it's the same prayer or
egypt
i'm sort of the same as him for me i
feel like it's such a long ways away
that i haven't even thought of where
exactly
probably egypt
what city do i enjoy competing with most
i guess new york you can get half of the
nancy
what's the hair for i like tokyo i like
tokyo australian meal
basically anywhere that i want it says
what was my first strawberry
job good job
if i have to leave the house quickly and
urgently
what is my go-to outfit
some nike sweats what do you call the
sports tank top
like a hoodie pretty much necklace
it's nike everything good job
what is one of my biggest goals
you want to start a fashion line you're
on fashion you want to win like 50 grand
slams
half a point what am i missing a lot
like what
honestly right now reading grand slams
he got that kind of rate um and then
olympics oh yeah i forgot my bad that
was a big one
my bad my bad that was a big one ah damn
i feel horrible gq decided that i should
ask you some questions
i feel like i have the basic questions
down but i don't know if there's gonna
be some
curveballs in there so okay uh
what is uh my favorite movie of all time
what what wait it's a damn shame
no no
wait that's a damn [ __ ] no wait
i can use like series but movies all
right that's fair that's fair i don't
really be watching movies like that my
favorite series
[Music]
what's my favorite what did i make you
watch
you made me watch all this stuff like
series
my favorite all-time series is
definitely the chappelle show
in boondocks a combination of those two
it's all right
what's my favorite fast food and what do
i order
yeah what did i study in college
pieces uh
mass communication close enough okay
what's my
biggest pet peeve you have a lot
um i would say it's when someone talks
about
music
what is uh our favorite show to watch
together this r
involves me and i'm involved in the r
you can make me watch your toe i do love
me snow that's how i ain't going for it
as much as as of lately are you supposed
to make the noise
what's my favorite meal that you cook
for um
[Music]
shrimp gnocchi with pesto
the fried chicken mac and cheese yeah
the homemade red lobster biscuits
well this is it this is how many cortea
are right
i don't recommend we don't even bring up
[Music]
and this is how many very cool names are
great
i do too
[Music]
you asked all the right questions you
did it you gained the layup you gave me
the easy questions
this was the gq's couple's quiz he's
trying to say
thanks for watching oh yeah thanks for
watching